spectacular
it's phenomenal you know and just be out
here i'm looking over there at the trees
like
i can't believe trees get that tall
world
we hear it we say it we believe it but
can we see it
the effect
when the game's online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable
they're it faster they make the players
around them better
be it factor welcome to the it factory
for the quarterbacks when they arrive at
the opening the mentality is that
we've kind of been through the fire all
12 quarterbacks
are in the elite 11 class for 2016.
but also the competition is still on as
they are all seeking to become the mvp
and dominate in the seven on seven
competition my expectation coming to the
opening
is be precise and to have the same chip
on the shoulder
that i did in la if you looked literally
on your smartphone and looked up the
word compete
it would say to strive against but if
you go way back
and look at the latin root of the word
like where the word actually began
it's defined as striving together so
like we said the first day the very
first day you guys
met everybody at your regional camp then
you made it to los angeles for the
eleven finals now here at the opening
it's all about the 12 best competitors
who can
make one another better how do we strive
together to have the most amazing week
under the sun
the greatest dynamic we see every year
at the opening is this
we see guys shrink and we see guys rise
up
we've had a lot of big fishes and small
ponds this is a big ass pond
and you got to be a big ass fish to have
command of your teams
i'm thankful to be here i really am i
think there's so many talented guys out
there that
they very well could have been in our
shoes but i think it's a great
opportunity and a great chance to
further some bonds i made in la
we all share a unique bond we just feel
comfortable around each other we can
goof around and when we need to be
serious we can be so
it's fun to all have the same mindset
still competing for the mvp
but everyone's realizing we're all in
the same boat we're the only people that
are experiencing this and
it's something we're going to enjoy and
have some fun out here
and as we get here for a few days before
all the athletes show up and the games
start
we have these three really robust days
of training
this is as good of opportunity as you're
gonna get to improve as you will ever
have
so what i would say to you guys i have
an open mind and i'm gonna learn as much
as i possibly can
this is as close to a college
environment that these guys are gonna
have
this is a finesse play this is watch how
crafty i am
throwing some dimes right now he's chill
like typical stanford because like
that's their prototypical what they look
like and when he throws two
it's crazy these guys are in high school
so what you're doing is you're swinging
your left arm down
lose control of the ball so when you
warm up tomorrow tuck your thumb and
your dry fist like this
yep hold the ball normal carriage and
throw
see how different it is
the second he gets open all right is
when we want to throw
that's the tempo oh there we go
i'm really adamant about maximizing
every minute of the teaching you know at
the end of the day um
just have fun just enjoy high school we
want to use the counselor's
wisdom and information to help these
kids grow we live in a world of
competition and competition
is good but it can become unhealthy when
you let it consume you
and you worry so much about what critics
are saying about you
what other people think about you and
you've got to learn
how to manage that you know all of you
guys are definitely high recruited
highly talented when you step on
campus everyone will know who you are
get a text message it's like peyton
demanding saying
hey good luck man i'll see you on the
sideline i'll be there today but just
want to wish you good luck and it's like
that's penny manny i don't even know
what to text back crazy
stuff like that i know i found my
purpose and my why
and my reasoning why i'm in this
position
and it's not to be great on the football
field it's
inspire young people and share my story
of what i went through so people from
you know my hood my hometown that never
made it out
can have hope and dreams la was one
thing but here at the opening the
coaching
is unbelievable as a defensive
perspective how we looked at things
my job was to solely was you guys up
and to see if you were scared if you
were weak
it was my job to make you quit willie's
a no-nonsense guy he doesn't
sugarcoat a lot of stuff and he didn't
sugarcoat it with the kids like hey you
want a factor
toughness tom brady he didn't look like
an
athlete but mentally he was one of the
toughest mothers
you ever meet and one of the most
competitive
guys you'll ever meet now that you're
here don't be satisfied with that fellas
you got to go above and beyond
the people that truly know the it factor
within their son
are the ones that raised them so our
staff
asked the parents and the guardians to
send a letter in of what they love about
their son
what they admire about their son why
they are so excited about the future
of their son every kid
you get true emotion
you get a beyond the x's and o's moment
this is way bigger than football
as we had a conversation with the
quarterbacks after they read the letter
you realize how emotional and how
impactful
parents can be just being able to get
the opportunity to
just finally hear from my mom you know
with but just everything that's going on
her side
you know it means a lot
for me it was the opposite um you know
you always hear it from my mom
you know she's a lovely person just
she's an incredible mom
and then i don't always get the the kind
of the feeling things from my dad
and i was just touching to hear it from
him
sam we all saw your story what was it
like reading
a letter from your mom uh actually she
put a letter
from my dad in there and so that kind of
hit me
pretty deep just from a from a while ago
and that just made me realize that all
this is great
and all this but it doesn't mean
anything
unless you have family and a support
system and i'm just very thankful for
that
it was like the first line when i read
it and my mom said she was proud of me
and
just hearing it just kind of i don't
know
it just like it hit me and then her
bringing up avery
huffman who passed away from the cancer
that wasn't curable and i dedicated my
season to her
so that kind of just came all back to me
the point is is that all too often in
our race
to become elite they sometimes can
forget the things that really matter
along the way
nego is an amazing foundation in my
hometown stands for never ever give up
and we focus our efforts on
children battling cancer some
local courageous kids who are battling
some tough stuff right now
come and have an amazing day with us but
then on the other side of it
these young developing quarterbacks get
to have an experience where they
are hit right in the face with something
that's very real very raw
just like you i work out a lot
by not working out to play in a football
game
i'm working out to get better so when
you give me a
high five a fist bump or even a pat on
the back
holds me to need you when i look at my
knee your wristband
i remember i'm not alone i need you do
you
every kid that has cancer deserves to be
encouraged to never
ever give up you're gonna meet some of
the most courageous kids that are
for the moment that you spend with them
they won't
think that they have cancer
and that is a great day we're gonna put
them through a little skills competition
right here
we want high energy fired up this is
their bcs national championship game
today
it's the biggest moment of their
football careers put a hole in that
thing
leo which was my partner and i know um
she didn't want to go through the thing
without holding my hand so i kind of
went out there with her
just seeing that really put a smile on
my face and lifted me up some
when you put some things in perspective
everyone wants to be the best here but
it's really not about us and it's not
about
anything that we're gonna accomplish
it's more about why we're
accomplishing great things who we can
touch
on the way when shawn gave his joy jar
to his courageous kid and the first
thing she did was
take the first toy out and give it to
somebody else look at that
you gonna give it to him that's so nice
of you
she uh went over to her little brother
in the stroller
and put it on him and like gave it to
him and i kind of just like
was just like wow this this girl does
not care about what's going on she just
wants to be there for anyone else so he
kind of
you know hit me in the heart it's so
cool to see these quarterbacks get
inspired
by the heart and the fight that these
kids have
nike's campus it's a packed house
can you deal when it gets hard that
is what seven on seven is gonna prove to
us as we figure out who the mvp is
your choice offense well we got the ball
it's the best group of pastors we've
ever had one through twelve there's not
a ton
separating twelve from one so they are
primed and ready
to go i think it goes back to uh when
you're a little kid when you're playing
recess football when you're playing in
the backyard
to be elite you have to be ultimate
competitor
kind of a gamer mentality where as soon
as the whistle blows you just breathe
focus
explode whenever you're in
these kinds of competitive environments
what you want to do is you want to do
what you do best
that's where the you know the real
competitors come through the more
intense the moment the more pure they
are to who they are
to be an 811 you have it people feel
that people sense it
but it's not just about you it's about
the people around you let's go
the mvp of the elite 11 their opening is
going to have to deal
they're going to deal with coaches
they're going to deal with players
they're going to deal with tv
cameras everywhere the guy that does
that's going to win the mvp
all the best dudes in the country have
fun play loose alignment assignment then
let it go
in the past at the opening the the
quarterback that's risen to the occasion
is
capture the elite 11 mvp go go
you don't have to win it to be the mvp
but it certainly helps
hey coach let's run that bullet again i
like that
nice ball tour tua tagovailoa has a
great body of work he started building
towards the end of today
rip really good play sean sean clifford
had an
awesome day he made some great throws he
was a leader
besides jake prom i thought he had the
second best day by far
oh again yeah bart you saw jake fromm
today come out and light the world on
fire
i normally don't say a whole lot about
throws but that's a good thrill
oh yeah oh
davis mills also turned it on towards
the end creates high
let's go back james don't worry about
the ball come on
we're in those situations i know i'm the
coach and i'm getting everybody lined up
but i would love as you grow and you get
older to have more of a presence
i guess i'm just used to that just yeah
and when you go to clemson and you're
competing as a freshman
you don't have a presence and it's even
with a guy who does go with a guy's
presence
you know what i mean so just kind of
exert yourself a little bit more
guys that were out in front did not
perform as well in pool play on day one
that it allowed
other guys to catch up
never leave that short throw it into the
bushes before you leave it short he
handles himself in a very mature way
but dylan he does not like to lose at
all go through it
hey hey we're working week the whole way
post corner to shallow right there you
wanna eyes that right away
yeah yeah we're just going post corner
to a shallow make sense
don't get so caught up in what they're
doing do your job and do it well
you did it great early in the week trey
is absolutely right
that's why this is here we got to keep
doing this we don't want a team with
peaks here because
every time we out there we got to get a
little bit better as competitive as he
is as much as he wants to win this
he actually didn't let the adversity
from game one
suck the energy out of his game or his
teammates game
he's a kid that's not afraid to have a
setback and learn from it
you know he's someone i think expects
that he expects greatness out of himself
and he's not surprised by it
yes let's me something go
way to win that hey way to make it look
good way to make me look good
overall i am very very proud of how you
guys handled the day
but tomorrow you got to make sure you
control what you can control
and that you communicate with these guys
all the time
there is no such thing as a quiet
quarterback leader
there's just no such thing the streets
are littered with five-star quarterbacks
that didn't have the it
so when we play these games on the final
day
this is what i want it's very clear i
want decisiveness
when you make a decision make it don't
doubt it
let it rip you're in control of your
experience tomorrow
make it awesome
you're the most mentally tough dude here
you've seen a lot of football in your
life your pedigree is built for this
you got me yep all right believe in
yourself all the guys believe you
believe in your ability go out there and
do what you do sir you got me
yep there we go get vertical that's it
let's get this y'all let's go we're
gonna chase on it oh it's terry stairs
there you gotta throw it earlier
jake if it's not there just going i want
drums around the corner
we worked on that to throw the arrow it
came wide open
yesterday i got away with a bunch of
stuff and today
honestly i still felt i did my job i
agree it just didn't interesting
nothing there was nothing beyond just
your job today
which is some there's days like that
we have the two guys that came in one or
two two attack of vialoa
and davis mills competing for the
championship and the mvp
this whole competition's been close now
you guys in the championship game
uh we've made it so close that we're
going to determine the mvp of elite 11
by this game yes sir right yes
appreciate it coach thank you fall out
hey man
go get it love you bro have fun go get
it let's go everybody in everybody
and let's go god is good god is good god
is good
god's good all the time all the time
let's go big o big one three one two
three let's go let's go boys
stop the seam get back there you go get
him in space get him in space
come on
hey we got one play to get inside the
20s everybody understand that
okay one play to get inside the 20 and
then we're good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go
hey
great job buddy
they got to do something to disrupt
their timing you're nice out
good job boys good job good job
hey good job hey thanks man appreciate
it
good job man appreciate it super proud
of you thank you coach appreciate it
thank you
god is good all the time god is good all
three one two three
oh that was good your journey to be here
in football heaven started with some
hard lonely work
so saying that to a stand-up
i challenged you about six weeks ago to
stand up
i said you're a heck of a football
player you're an incredible athlete but
i didn't see
the discipline in your game to be a
quarterback
i could not have been more wrong and i'm
so happy i was wrong
of all the kids i've ever coached i've
never seen one
improve more rapidly than you you have
uniqueness in you
your arm talent is supreme i think it
pales in comparison to what you have in
here
you know something really special in
here too and you will change the world
i am so proud of you that you're the
2016 elite 11 mvp
the it factor we hear it we hear it
we hear it we say it we say it
we say it we believe it
but can we see it
some argue yes of course it's right in
front of you others say oh no
this thing cannot be captured and it's
nowhere near a playbook
and it's nowhere near a playbook
so this is factor the most undefinable
overused phrase
how do we quantify it how do we quantify
it break it rank
it rank it or simply say c
the it factor the it factor
so let's agree okay this factor is
something we can't describe
something we can't describe other than
something we constantly seek to describe
to develop to develop to develop to
develop to nurture
to nurture to nurture to learn all about
so this is factor the most undefinable
overused phrase
has gained so much clout on tv and staff
rooms
beyond
as women we have a really different it
factor for you
you want a man who stands for something
that's bigger than himself
the it factor the it factor the it
factor
this phrase it's the ever undefinable
phrase
now some say you either have it or you
don't either have it
or you don't you won't be this you want
to be that
you either have it or you don't hear the
factory
no one ever says won't here's about
diving in the lonely world
the love of doing the boring things
longer than the other
the lonely work
and it's developed under the bright
lights and dimly lit ones
now let's be clear okay to be elite you
must compete to be elite you must
compete
so when you do tap in so when you do tap
in do it for real
fight let's go let's go
dig dig i know it hurts wait a sec
perfect nice throw do it for real do it
for real so go
say it out loud say it out loud the hit
factor the it factor the it factor be it
factor
the most undefinable it's a place where
we embrace grit
it's not a summer camp it's not a summer
camp it's the place where we develop
are it welcome to the it factory
you